The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
What I want to do today
is look ahead and
talk a little bit
about where the grid's going.
This is going to
be based largely
on that future of the electric
grid study that a bunch of us
did.
You'll see in the Joskow
paper a fair amount of overlap
and an awful lot of agreement,
although his emphasis is
a bit different.
So let me start with what
the system looks like now.
That's a picture of line
losses in transmission
and distribution.
That's heat,
basically waste heat.
And that's gone down
sharply over time.
It floats around 6-7%.
These appear to be
in line with line
losses in other
developed countries,
if you make allowance
for density.
They're higher in
Canada and Australia.
They're lower in
Germany and France
because it's more
compact countries.
But you can put us all
more or less on a line.
Reliability is a little tougher.
You might ask the
question, is the US system
more or less reliable
than systems elsewhere?
And the answer is we
don't know because data
on reliability and other
aspects of performance
are terrible in the US.
You might ask why that is?
I'll suggest an answer.
And it has to do with the
structure of regulation.
If I measure-- if I use
a standard definition
of an outage, and I measure how
often my customers don't have
power, how many
outages, how long
they last, and you do the same,
and I'm above you in outages,
people yell at me.
If nobody knows,
nobody yells at me.
These things are just
not measured in the US.
I mean, they're
measured in some states.
They're not reported in some
states where they're measured.
And different definitions are
used all over the country.
There is now a standard
IEEE definition for outages.
And it's spreading slowly.
But even then, it's not
reported in lots of places.
So we cannot tell if the system
is more or less reliable than
it was in 1930,
which is bizarre.
But there's more.
So I'm going to talk about
most of the terrain we covered
in the future of the grid.
We focused on 2030 because
of the speed at which things
change, the grid in
2030 will be dominated
by technologies we know today.
Not necessarily
technologies in widespread
use, but stuff we know.
Stuff we don't know,
that's invented tomorrow,
is unlikely to
penetrate by then.
So we said, what are the big
challenges and opportunities?
And these are the
ones we focused on.
There are a bunch
of new technologies.
Will they get developed
and used properly?
There will be more
large-scale wind and solar.
We'll talk about the
issues that raises.
There'll be more
electric vehicles.
How many more, nobody knows.
But more, and in some
places a fair amount.
There'll be more distributed
generation, rooftop solar,
on various kinds of roofs,
and some distributed wind.
And the system will be more
reliant on communications
and computation,
which means there'll
be more of an issue
of cybersecurity
and an issue of
information privacy.
People will know every 15
minutes how much electricity
you're using.
And you might not want
everybody to know that.
So to remind you of
some of the constraints,
I talked last time--
last Wednesday-- about
the state/federal divide.
States are important.
There's not much evidence--
not much appetite after
the California debacle and
after the Lehman crisis--
the whole crisis-- not
much appetite for reform.
Very diverse system--
municipal utilities, co-ops,
big utilities, little
utilities; vertically
integrated in some
places, federally owned
in other places.
There's not much
growth expected.
7/10 of a percentage
point a year
is the standard case
forecast out to 2035.
And very durable assets.
This is actually a number.
I had it last year.
The forecast number has
doubled since last year,
but it's still low.
Anybody care to guess
what fraction of 2000--
what fraction of--
let's say 2010 capacity
will be retired by 2035?
AUDIENCE: 1%.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, now you're reaching.
No.
It's higher than that.
It's higher.
It's almost 7%.
Last year, it was 3.5%.
Last year, the
estimate was 3.5%.
The difference is mainly
environmental retirements
and really cheap gas.
So the notion is, because of
really cheap gas and tighter
environmental policy, 7% of
capacity will be retired.
That's not a lot of
turnover in 25 years.
That's not a lot of turnover.
So the generating fleet is going
to look a lot like it does now,
a lot like it does now.
Andrew?
AUDIENCE: This is for a base
case assumption, like the--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it
has no assumption
about environmental regulations
or something like that?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: No.
This is EIA, the Energy
Information Administration.
And their base case assumes
no change in current policy.
So one of the things
that it used to assume--
in fact, it does assume--
it assumes that current
renewable subsidies,
which have--
you don't-- laws don't
have infinite lifetimes.
The law expires at some point.
It assumes that expires.
So it'll be a little
light on renewables.
They'll run some other
cases-- they're not out yet--
assuming more
renewables, assuming
higher prices and lower prices.
But that's the base case.
OK, so not much turnover.
the argument is--
that we have made--
is that the grid does have these
challenges and opportunities,
the turnover is slow.
If you want to get
anything done in 2035,
you've got to start now.
A little bit about
the smart grid.
And it's not a term
I like because it
means different things
to different people.
And here are four examples.
This is the National Institute
of Standards and Technologies'
favorite diagram because--
and it stresses that
the grid in the future
will have this flow
of power, of course--
but lots of flows of data.
And why do they
stress that view?
Because they're doing
this interface standards.
They're doing standard setting
for all of those flows.
That's a big deal.
This is EPRI over here,
the Electric Power Research
Institute.
EPRI's view of the smart grid
has to do with things that go--
that happen around the user.
So there's some focus--
some automation of the
distribution system,
and plug-in hybrids, and smart
refrigerators, and rooftop
solar.
They focus on your house.
This is somebody in nature.
And in nature, they
focus on microgrids.
Or in this picture, they
focus on microgrids, which we
can talk about if you want to.
But it's not something
that we think
is going to be a big deal.
And this is the Department
of Energy, which
has it all, which has it all.
So as the title says, I guess--
my view is that "smart"
is a means, not an end.
You don't care how
smart the grid is.
What you care is,
what's its performance
and what's its cost?
It will get smarter.
But that's not the objective.
That's the means.
So I went through some of the
challenges and constraints.
We focused on a bunch
of policy areas.
So let me talk first
about technology.
Here I immediately
get out of my depth,
but I will do what I can.
There's really a lot
of interesting stuff.
I'm going to talk about
phasor measurement
units in a few minutes.
Flexible AC
transmission systems let
you vary the
characteristics of lines
so that you can to some
extent control flows.
I told you last time that
electric power networks are not
really like sort of old-style
telephone systems or water
systems.
You don't do valves.
You can sort of do valves.
New sensor technologies lets
you know the state of the lines.
So that on a hot day, you put
less electricity through them
because you can see
they're sagging.
And there are a bunch of-- well,
dynamic line rating systems
deal with automating the
readings from these sensors.
Energy storage, I'll
talk about, and a bunch
of other technologies.
Farther on down, toward the
customers, the low voltage
stuff, there's a
lot of automation
at the substation
that's possible,
quicker detection of outages,
optimization of-- the Volt/VAR
optimization
controls-- enables you
to control voltage levels,
particularly on long lines,
more accurately.
Conservation voltage
reduction lets
you reduce voltage on the
whole system just a little bit,
to save a lot of energy.
There are places
where the voltage
is above the requirement because
you can't properly control it.
So it ends-- and you
have to keep it above--
you have to keep it within
a certain bound everywhere.
If you can control better,
you can reduce it everywhere.
Automated fault detection
is really quite interesting.
The interesting part is
automatic restoration.
Advanced metering systems
are very important.
And I will talk about those.
And, of course, this
all comes together
where you control the grid.
And I'm going to talk
about particularly using
these meters in a little
while, and right now making
the control center work.
So here's-- if it
works, if it works--
my favorite movie.
All right.
I've played this a million
times in a million places.
And it's never been this bad.
Let me tell you what you would
have seen if this had worked.
What you would--
this is the result
of an outage in southern
Florida in 2008.
And what you're seeing-- those
red dots are phasor measurement
units that describe--
that pick up the state
of the system in terms
of frequency and phase angle of
voltage and current, many times
a second, time stamped.
So that, in principle,
they give a picture
of the state of the
whole system instant
by instant, which
we do not now have.
The red dots are where
the measurements are made.
The spaghetti chart on
the left is the readings
from individual ones.
And the folks at Virginia Tech,
who invented the measuring
systems, have basically
interpolated and extrapolated
to put together a picture
of the whole system.
What's interesting
here-- there are a couple
of things interesting here.
First of all-- and I won't hurt
your eyes by playing it again--
what's interesting here is,
one, the geographic extent.
So if something
happens in Florida--
and the frequency
distortion most durably
is in northern
Minnesota or Canada.
You may be able to see that.
The second is, it happens fast.
This is 25 seconds.
So here's where it goes out.
Boom.
It is happening--
there are things
all around the country,
all around the Eastern
Interconnect, and most durably
up there in northern Minnesota.
So it's fast.
There's a lot of data.
You couldn't react
to it as a human.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does the setting move?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Well,
let me see if I can freeze it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: It's
the extent of the departure.
Let me just-- it
doesn't want to stop.
Red-- red means, I
think, that it's--
yeah.
It means it's faster
than 60 cycles a second.
The frequency locally is higher.
Blue means it's slower.
So you're getting
a-- you're getting
a pattern a distortion--
slight distortion-- in system
frequency.
Now, in this case,
nothing terrible happened.
Blackout happened in Florida.
Boom.
Disturbance propagates
throughout the whole Eastern
Interconnect within
a matter of seconds.
So, A, nobody could
respond to that.
And nobody looking at the data
on-- the graph on the left
or the map on the
right could think
through what to do in time.
If there were something
serious, that's just
too fast with so much data.
So the great thing
about these units
is they give control systems--
control centers-- a picture of
the grid over a wide scale that
has never existed before
in real time, lots of data.
This is just one aspect of
it, frequency distortion.
But nobody knows
what to do with it.
There's another picture that
is in the movie, which says
if you look before the 2000--
when was the last
big blackout, 2008--
you see a phase angle
change near Cleveland
over a period of about 30
seconds and then it breaks.
So if you actually knew
what that angle should be,
and measured it, and
had a monitoring system,
you might have been able
to tell that the system was
about to break.
But not everybody that
has one of these units
actually shares
data in real time.
We don't have control systems
to use the data in real time.
The federal government
has subsidized
putting these boxes out
there to measure the system.
But we don't have the
ability to respond.
I mean, you're sitting
there in a control room.
You see this thing.
Is this a problem,
is it not a problem?
All of a sudden, frequencies are
changing throughout the Eastern
Interconnect.
Do I need to isolate New England
to avoid a blackout up here?
Well, the answer,
it turns out was no.
But without a lot
of automation, you
wouldn't be-- and a good
model of the system,
you wouldn't be
able to know that.
So moving right along.
So you see the issue that we've
got this incredible source
of real-time data,
with no ability
to use it and not much sharing.
And your tax dollars
have produced it.
It's terrific.
But we don't know how to use it.
I mentioned these devices that
control the transmission system
and enhance capacity.
They're expensive.
The ideal way to
use them would be
to use this data from
phasor measurement units
through an automated
control system
to modify line characteristics.
We've got the fax devices.
We've got the phasor
measurement units.
We do not have any
system to link them.
So we think that's
sort of a useful thing
to do since the
boxes are out there.
It's also the case
that there are
a lot of so-called smart
grid technologies going in
at the distribution level.
Your tax dollars, or
rather the deficits
you will fund later
on, have funded
putting out a lot of very smart
boxes in distribution systems.
But what they do hasn't
yet been published.
So it's a little unclear.
AARA is the stimulus
legislation.
So we need more
R&D, pretty cheap
R&D. We need computational
tools to use all this data.
It should have impressed
you with how closely
coupled that whole
Eastern Interconnect is.
That from Florida to Minnesota,
very quickly a disturbance
propagates.
That means, if you think about
it, particularly if you think
about renewables, which
I'll come to in a second,
you need to be able to
plan at the level of--
at that level, at the level
of the Eastern system.
The Western system is simpler.
Texas is simpler.
The Eastern system
is the big one.
We can't begin to plan that.
The dimensionality is too
high for current techniques.
And just to get to things I
will come to in a little while,
there's a lot of focus on
preventing cyber attacks.
There's very little
effort on what
do you do when you
get one, one succeeds.
But one will succeed.
And we need to understand
more about automated--
about dynamic pricing.
I'll come to it.
This is a troublesome thing.
There are technologies that have
been standard in Scandinavia
for 20 years, that are
required in India, that
can't be sold in this country
because no utility has ever
seen it work.
The level of risk aversion
is kind of breathtaking.
And it's like, why
don't we measure things?
Because if we put it in, and
it's new, and it doesn't work,
the utility gets hammered.
The utility management
gets hammered.
The stockholders get punished.
And the regulator gets punished.
If you put it in and it
works, everybody yawns.
So the regulatory system
here in particular
is biased against
innovation in a way
that's hard to fix
because it's political.
It's not technical.
It's political.
OK, what about renewables?
Well, there's going to
be more wind and solar.
This is renewable generation
in the US, up to 2007.
You see the big story is--
the big growth story is wind.
Wood is very important.
A lot of that is waste
from lumber mills,
that they just use
it to generate power.
Some of them sell to the
grid, some of them don't.
Maine, a few years ago,
passed a requirement
for renewable generation.
Did the numbers.
Realized they had already
met the requirement because
of all the lumber mills.
You'll see solar here.
Solar is in the data.
But it's too small to
see in the picture.
Since 2007, you see this peaks
at about-- what do you figure--
100,000.
It's 173,000 in 2010.
Over half of that was wind.
So you see the wind--
wind has continued to drive
the growth through 2010.
So that's renewables in the US.
There are a lot of policies.
That's Europe.
This is putting aside hydro.
We were way ahead of
Europe around 1990.
We've stayed pretty
constant as a percentage
of total generation.
Europe has shot up.
And the European goal--
the EU goal is--
well, 20% of all
energy from renewables.
So 35% of electricity
from renewables by 2020--
very, very ambitious.
There is-- well, you see Maine.
This is 2007, non-hydro
renewable generation
as a percentage of
the state total.
Maine leads because
of all the wood.
California, pretty high;
mostly geothermal, but wind
and solar coming.
And Texas, just an absolute
generation, with a lot of wind,
a lot of wind.
This is a policy map.
It shows you the 29 states
and the District of Columbia
have renewable
portfolio standards.
Those are state
laws that require--
generally, that require
if you sell electricity
at retail, x percent of
that has to be renewable.
Usually much more detail--
you know.
New Jersey has a requirement
for off-shore, in-state wind.
North Carolina has a requirement
for electricity produced from--
I think it's
poultry waste, maybe
a separate one for swine waste.
And they all vary.
Rhode Island has three
different levels of requirement.
So there's a lot of
push for renewables.
They're called renewable
portfolio standards
because the notion is, in
your portfolio of generation
so much of it has
to be renewable.
And we could talk
about how these work.
But-- well, they're
all different.
But you don't necessarily have
to be physically connected
to a renewable generator.
But you have to
make a purchase that
amounts to encouraging
that much generation.
I used to be able to say
that every state but Arkansas
subsidized renewables.
But Arkansas put in
a subsidy in 2010.
So every state subsidizes
renewables now.
Now, here's issue one.
Issue one is, here's
where the wind is.
There's a lot of good wind
offshore, in the Great Lakes.
But offshore is expensive.
The good onshore
wind tends to be
in the middle of the country.
People tend not to be in
the middle of the country.
So if you're going
to use that, you're
going to have to
build transmission.
And that transmission is going
to have to cross state lines.
I mean, there's a lot
of wind in North Dakota.
There are not a lot of
people in North Dakota
despite the shale boom.
If you're going
to use that wind,
you're probably going to have
to go from North Dakota, oh,
at least to Minneapolis,
and maybe down to Chicago,
which is a problem.
Even in New England--
this is an impossible map.
But it shows you where the wind
is in New England, up here.
That's offshore.
This is where the load is
in Massachusetts, and Rhode
Island, and Connecticut.
To get wind from Northern
Maine, down here,
you've got across state lines.
The problem is, states
approve power lines.
And states can
block power lines.
So my favorite is there was
a proposal from Southern
California Edison to
build a line into Arizona,
to connect to some
cheap generation,
and take the power
to Los Angeles.
And the Arizona
Commission vetoed it.
And one commissioner
said, that's a 230,000--
a 230-mile straw sucking
energy out of Arizona.
We won't do it.
OK, each state
can block it if it
crosses federally
owned land, which
is I think a third of
the land in the country.
The federal agency can block it.
Nobody can say, yes.
We can build gas pipelines
because those are federally--
federally done.
The FERC approves gas pipelines.
There is no such
approval for power lines.
Well, if you're going to do
renewables, there has to be.
So one of our recommendations
is to change that law.
This is not necessarily
popular at the state level.
Because as I said,
there's a lot of holding
of power by the states.
But if you want to build renew--
you want to use renewables that
come from remote
areas, you need to have
somebody who can say yes.
OK so far?
Questions on any of this?
OK, that's one issue
with renewables.
The other issue with
renewables is the fact
that you can't dispatch them.
You can't control them.
This is-- that's the output
from a photovoltaic plant,
solar cells, on a
partly cloudy day.
The output can
change very rapidly,
in a matter of seconds.
There is no inertia
in the system,
no inertia in the system.
Now, if you a bunch of them,
spread out geographically,
this problem is reduced, but
not eliminated because sometimes
a whole state will be cloudy.
So that's a real issue.
And the no inertia means--
you think about the way power
systems currently operate,
there's a lot of rotating metal
in generators, and turbines,
and such, but particularly
in generators.
So if all of a sudden, 5,000
people turn on the lights,
that's a big increase in load.
But the system has what you
call ride through capability.
You know, you've
got all this inertia
going through-- going
in the generators.
It just carries
you through bumps.
Well, there's no inertia here.
There's nothing carrying
you through bumps.
And there's no real
inertia in wind turbines.
Not a serious
problem at all, yet.
But as you look down the road to
a lot of it, potentially it is.
Wind-- this is total output
of wind in California.
The top line and the bottom
line are individual facilities.
And the access-- these are--
well, this is a
whole day, right.
So it's 10 seconds--
10-second second sampling.
These are hours.
And this is sort of
characteristic of wind.
Wind-- wind ramps,
not minutes or seconds
really, except for maybe
some individual windmill
that gets a gust.
But over any
reasonable area, it can
ramp in the course of hours,
from nothing to a lot,
or from a lot to nothing.
Both of those are problems.
This is the most discouraging
graph I've seen on wind.
This is a week in
July 2006, when
it was very hot in California.
And the green is
wind generation.
So you'll notice that--
it has wind capacity
of 2,600 megawatts.
That week wind never produced
more than a thousand.
And it varies over the course
of the day, substantially.
But here's the kicker.
The red dots are the
times of the system peak.
The red dots are when the
system really needed power--
late afternoon, in
a very hot week.
When it's really hot, the wind
tends not to blow that much.
So not only is there
a lot of variation
that the system has to respond
to, but at least in this case,
the peak out--
the output at peak
was tiny relative to capacity.
So wind farms tend to have
capacity factors, 20s and 30s.
That is to say, about 20%
to 30% of nominal capacity.
If you ran at 2,600 megawatts,
24 hours a day, you'd get x.
What you actually get over
x is the capacity factor.
And it tends-- they
tend to be 20%, 30%.
Solar, not so much at night.
So that's the other
problem with renewables,
that you can't dispatch them.
They're variable,
variable energy resources,
as the phrase goes.
This is another
terrific picture.
This is Bonneville.
This is the Pacific Northwest.
And this is over the course
of 2009, early December 2009.
Saturday night, wind the
output goes from nothing,
so around 2,000 megawatts.
Holds during the
day Sunday, Sunday
is not a high
demand day, and then
just as you're coming
into Monday, ramps down
to 0 by Monday night.
Now we're told that
Bonneville handled that.
Bonneville handled
that by backing off
everything they could
possibly back off,
and then bringing everything
they could possibly
bring up back online.
Not easy.
Double it, and the
system wouldn't have been
able to handle it, probably.
So wind output, solar output,
are more variable than demand.
And you can't
predict them as well.
There's a lot of work on
predicting these things.
There has not been
a lot of research
on forecasting wind
at 50-meter heights;
has not been a subject of
much interest in meteorology
until recently.
It's very interesting now.
Hard to get data, not a lot of
weather stations at 50 meters.
There are a lot of other
changes and thinking
about how you
reconfigure the system.
The interesting
thing from the point
of view of the market design
is you don't just need capacity
in a power system.
What you need now is
capacity that can ramp,
can go up fast, down fast.
The current market design
doesn't provide incentives
for building that
kind of capacity
or for making it available.
So again, as we go
forward, it's going
to be important to figure
out how to do this.
How do we make the system
more flexible so it
can respond to wind and solar
at higher levels of penetration?
Now, one answer that
everybody has is storage.
And here's from a recent
report on storage technologies.
There are lots of storage
technologies, lots of them.
The ones in widespread
use are pump storage.
And pump storage is
terrific at this, perfect.
There's a round trip loss.
You pump water uphill.
You run it down
through a turbine.
It's great.
You can start it fast, not
seconds, but pretty fast.
You can stop it pretty
fast, not instantly.
You got a lot of rotating metal.
But you can stop it pretty fast.
But you can't build it.
There's one in New England.
Nobody imagines we'll ever
be able to build another one.
It's the problem
of building dams.
You can't build dams.
So this is a technology
that's in some use,
you could build more of.
But this is
compressed air, mostly
in a cavern of one
kind or another.
Put a lot of air
in under pressure,
drive a turbine
when it comes out.
You can do that.
There are about three of
them I think in the world.
And then there are
all these batteries--
and supercapacitors,
which are kind of cute--
and flywheels.
And they work.
These are known technologies.
We can build these.
These are sort of neat.
These are batteries that are--
that basically work off either
liquid cathodes or anodes.
And things flow.
And it's great stuff.
And but they're all
really expensive at scale.
This, you can sort of
afford if you can build it.
This is OK where you
have a suitable site.
Not great, but it's OK.
And all this other
stuff is expensive.
So it's very hard.
This is the Holy Grail in
electric power research.
If you could do cheap
grid level storage,
solar and wind would
not be a problem.
But with technologies
we now know, you can't.
This stuff just does
not look to have
the prospect of
becoming cheap enough
to deploy at scale by 2030.
Could you do it?
Sure.
Could you afford
it, probably not.
OK, questions so far.
It's kind of a downer.
But there we are.
I mean, it is what it is.
And-- now the third thing.
They're remote.
They're intermittent.
And they're expensive.
So what do you do?
You can do R&D. We've done some.
You could do more easily.
There is an interesting
question of, should you
bring renewables on
by subsidizing them
or should you
bring renewables on
by taxing what you
don't like, which
is possibly coal, or carbon,
or oil, or some mixture?
There are carbon taxes in
various places in the world,
not that many.
What the US has done--
at the state level, we've
had these requirements.
What the Europeans have done
is to basically pay prices.
So if you put up a
solar farm in Germany,
your revenue per kilowatt hour
is guaranteed for 20 years.
In the US, you've got
to find a utility that
wants to deal with you, for
the fact that you're renewable.
One argument is, why do we
do it that way in the US?
There are lots of
problems with it.
Because the cost is hidden.
It hides the cost, I
think is the main reason.
It hides the cost.
In Germany, I mean you
know there's a price.
It's posted.
In Spain, there's a price.
In the US, how much
does solar and wind
add to our electric bills?
We don't have a clue.
Because there's--
there are deals done.
But they're not
typically public.
So we don't know.
The fact that-- you may or may
not have followed that onshore
wind was--
that the Cape Wind--
you all remember
Cape Wind, this project to
build a bunch of windmills
off Cape Cod, hugely
controversial, also expensive?
People were shocked
that the price
to be paid for that electricity
was three times the going
wholesale rate.
Shocked.
Well, you're building windmills
offshore, in the ocean,
with transmission.
And gas is really cheap.
People were shocked because--
there were a number
of interviews.
People said, well,
the wind is free.
OK, the wind is free.
So we do this--
the other thing we
do is tax breaks.
And tax breaks give
you this pattern.
This is wind additions
in megawatts over time.
And you might ask, why
it looks like that?
Whenever you see weird
business conduct,
the first thing you might
want to look at is tax policy.
These are the years in which
either the tax subsidy was
absent or in which
it wasn't clear it
was going to be renewed.
And when that
happens, people stop.
And, of course, if you want
to build a wind industry,
that's insane because
it means you can't ever
gear up for production
because next year you
might not have any orders.
It's also a little
problem with using--
we use tax breaks, too,
because that hides the cost.
You can cut revenue and
subsidize renewable power--
or cut taxes and subsidize
renewable power in one
fell swoop.
That's just fabulous.
But, of course, if the firm
doesn't have any profits,
it can't use a
profits tax break.
And a lot of money is
wasted making that work.
We also don't enforce much.
So we have probably the
worst possible policy mix.
And the only explanation
I've ever heard
is that it's perfectly
designed to hide the costs.
The tax breaks-- who
knows how much we spend.
I mean, you can--
it can be found
out, but not easily.
How much does it add
to the cost of power?
Well, it doesn't.
It adds to your income taxes.
What about these
renewable standards,
what do they add to
the cost of power?
Well, hard to know; bunches of
deals, bunches of contracts,
not ever really reported.
So we hide the cost pretty well.
A carbon tax would be
a much better approach.
I should tell you,
this is actually--
I find this fascinating.
But the latest word
from Washington
is that the carbon
tax is coming back.
Remember cap and
trade, the climate bill
that we were going to have
because both candidates
in the last
presidential election
supported having a cap and
trade program, which went down
to defeat as cap and tax?
Well, there now is serious--
serious work going on
in Washington, as
far as I can tell,
on both sides of the aisle,
preparing carbon tax bills.
They don't mention climate.
Turns out, it's OK to tax carbon
if you don't mention climate.
You mention revenue,
energy self-sufficiency.
So we're going to
have a carbon tax--
we may have a carbon
tax to raise revenue
without the word "climate"
being uttered in the debate.
It's fabulous stuff.
Anyway, that's renewables.
Questions, comments, reactions?
You're not terminally
depressed by all that?
OK.
All right, I'll
depress you some more.
Let's talk about prices.
Prices don't reflect the
nature of actual costs.
Demand varies over time.
You saw last time
a supply curve.
That says prices vary over time.
These are average-- these are
daily average prices over 2010,
in the PJM market area.
That began is Pennsylvania,
Jersey, Maryland.
It's now broader.
It's the biggest electricity
market in the country.
And you notice a
bunch of things.
You notice they vary.
You can sort of see
a seasonal pattern.
They tend to be a little
higher in the summer on average
than they are other
times of the year.
Not that much higher, because
other times of the year
you do your maintenance.
So the supply curve
shifts when you take units
off to maintain them.
This must have been a
particularly hot day.
Who knows what happened
here in December?
A unit went off.
So the point here is you'd
have kind of a hard time.
You could predict this
maybe that, yeah, it
tends to be lower in
the spring, and maybe
what the hell is that?
But you'd predict basically
a summer peak in prices.
But you'd miss a lot.
You'd miss a lot
of the variation.
You're talking down from $20
a megawatt hour up to $120.
And this is not--
if we deaveraged and
didn't do daily averages,
you'd get more of
a spread than that.
You can get several
orders of magnitude spread
in marginal cost of electricity.
You do not see that at home.
If you looked at the daily
level, it's even more striking.
This is a couple of
days in 2010 by hour.
And you see on whatever--
whichever of the two days
this is, you had
your morning peak
and you had your afternoon peak.
OK, you could kind
of predict that.
I have no idea what
happened on this day.
This is like 1:00 or 2:00 in the
afternoon, the prices shoot up.
And that's real.
That's the cost of generating
electricity at the margin.
That's a marginal cost.
And it's at $300
a megawatt hour,
they've put up pulled all
the old dirty diesels out
and turned them on
for an hour or two.
So you can't forecast that.
You don't pay that.
Small commercial and
residential users
don't see that
variation in cost.
Oranges get more
expensive at wholesale,
they're more
expensive at retail.
Power gets more expensive,
at wholesale nothing happens.
Now, it could happen.
I mentioned earlier,
advanced meters.
What advanced meters do is
advanced meters basically
record usage at shorter
short intervals,
say 15 minutes; can
receive price signals;
can send 15-minute or even
finer usage information
to the utility.
So you could use these.
And there are millions of
them around the country.
You could use them to
charge those prices.
You can imagine exactly
how popular that would be.
You come home one day.
And, oh, by the way you've
just spent a jillion dollars
for electricity because
something happened.
So these meters, they're
required in California.
They're required in
several other states--
everywhere.
Federal tax dollars--
your federal tax dollars--
have paid for millions of them.
But they're not being used.
They're very smart
meters, that are
going to go slowly insane not
using any of that intelligence.
They're not being
used for pricing.
They're not being used
for measuring every 15
seconds because-- or 15
minutes because who cares?
The price is the same.
So the one thing
everybody is convinced
of is if you just cut people
over to pricing like that,
there would be
riots in the street
because people would
have nasty surprises.
And people don't
like nasty surprises.
You go away for a week.
It's a heat wave.
You forgot to turn off
your air conditioner--
turn down your air conditioner.
Boom, $3,000 electricity bill.
You don't like that too much.
So it seems clear to most of
us that the only way this works
is if you can have simple
automated response,
simple automated response.
The main issue is going to be
air conditioning and heating.
But even so, you
might like some signal
that says don't do your clothes
at 5:00 in the afternoon.
Something that says
to you, electricity
is really expensive right now.
And for some things,
it's got to be automated.
The flip side of all
this price variation
is a change in low
duration curves.
You recall, these curves you
get by stacking the power--
by measuring power
consumption each hour,
and then graphing first the
hour with the highest use, then
second highest, and so
on, down to the lowest.
These are low duration
curves for New York,
rescaled so that the
peak is equal to 1,
and averaged over 1980,
'84, and 2005 to 2009.
You notice they change--
it changes shape.
It changes shape
kind of dramatically.
In '80 to '84, with
this 21% is, if you
adjust size the system to
meet peak demand exactly,
21% of your capacity would
be used fewer than a thousand
of the 8,760 hours in the year.
That's a lot of idle capital.
But it gets worse, 2005 to
2009, that curve is peak year--
technical term.
It has a sharper peak.
And over a third of your
capacity was used only
a thousand hours--
less than a thousand
hours a year.
So why?
Well, the data are
what the data are.
There's two explanations
that people have.
The first is air conditioning.
Because more central air
conditioning in particular
means more load on
hot summer days.
And hot summer days
of the system peaks.
So more air conditioning--
every unit in the state
is on these peak times.
And there are more
units in the state.
The other is that--
it's interesting.
If you look at the
numbers in the '50s,
industrial load was about
half of electricity usage,
about half.
And that tends not
to be seasonal.
And it also tends to
run at night a lot.
It's now down to
about 28% nationally.
So if it's all industrial
load that runs 24 hours a day,
this thing is flat.
But as you get less of that,
this back end falls off
and the top end goes
comparatively higher.
Now, everybody's got
an air conditioner.
But what happens when you
have an appreciable number
of electric vehicles and
everybody comes home from work
and plugs them in?
So a plug-in electric charge
that's sort of high capacity
is a house.
I mean, it's comparable
in terms of load.
So electric vehicles, in
areas where they penetrate,
have the ability to make
this problem a lot worse.
And the reason it's a
problem is you've got
to pay for all that capacity.
That's capital sitting there
that has to get paid for.
So rates go up.
So electric vehicles could
have a disproportionate impact,
if they spread, on rates.
I personally don't
think they're going
to spread that much--
they're going to have
great penetration by 2030.
I'd love to be wrong.
But in some areas--
Southern California,
they expect--
probably Cambridge.
I mean, who knows.
But-- well, except for
batteries and cold weather.
But Southern California
Edison monitors
automobile purchases
in Beverly Hills,
and Brentwood, and
various other rich areas
in Southern California.
In Palo Alto, I'm told you
can see parades of Teslas
every so often.
So there are some
areas that will have
a lot of electric vehicles.
And the obvious thing to do
is if you take it to work,
you plug it in
when you come home.
And that's exactly
when the system peaks.
That's exactly when
the system peaks.
So it could make this worse.
So if you can move
loads off-peak,
move charging to the
middle of the night,
have people dry their
clothes at night--
run the air conditioner,
as I'm told Walmart does,
really hard at 5:00 and
6:00 in the morning,
and then back it off during the
day; and run it hard at noon,
and back it off
in the afternoon,
you could flatten the curve.
But-- and there are
programs in which demand
responds to peak conditions.
There are something like
2 million air conditioners
in Florida that are
centrally controlled.
And the utilities are allowed
to basically turn them--
well, turn them up in
terms of temperature
in system emergencies or system
stress periods, not every day.
But in principle, pricing
can take care of this.
If you can make this
electricity really
expensive in those hours,
you bring that peak down,
use capacity more effectively,
deal with electric vehicles.
I mean, some people have
said, well, you really
shouldn't allow people to charge
their electric vehicles at 5:00
in the afternoon.
That is not
politically possible.
Can you imagine being told
you can't refuel your vehicle,
and go out in the evening?
No, that's not going to happen.
If you can't make it
a rule, then maybe
you have to make it expensive.
Well, how do you
make it expensive?
Well, you use price.
The technology is out there.
You just have to do it.
So we think this is
actually important.
We also think this
is going to happen.
But there has to be some way
to make it easy for households.
The Department of Energy,
some few years ago,
put out a brochure
in which you talked
about new technology will
let every household be
an active participant in
the electricity market.
Electricity is about 2% of
the average household budget.
Milk is probably more important.
The notion that
people actually want
to sit around and look at
electricity prices all day,
that's nutty.
But you got to-- if you
want to have them respond,
they have to be able to
automate the response.
And that technology is just--
a lot of people playing in it.
But it's not--
it's not there yet.
People like Cisco drool at
this, as you can imagine.
Cisco has hired people
from electric utilities.
Cisco is talking to
appliance makers.
Cisco sees this as a future.
But we're not there yet.
As I say, there are a
lot of these meters out.
Your tax dollars have
paid for millions
of meters that are
going slowly insane,
not using their intelligence.
So we actually think that
it's pretty important
to begin running sensible
experiments and sharing data,
so that we can actually
deal with this issue using
the technology we have.
Questions here?
OK.
Let me talk about
distributed generation.
This is a pure economic issue.
And if you think about
it for a little while,
it's a really easy
economic issue,
but it's politically impossible.
So there are subsidies for
distributed generation,
rooftop, solar.
California talks about
a million solar roofs.
Everybody loves it; except,
of course, the utilities.
And the utilities don't
like it for two reasons.
One reason is, the
grid isn't designed
to have power generated out
on the edge, particularly
the distribution system.
The simplest example is this.
Suppose the utility needs to
work on a power line connecting
to your house.
So what do they do now?
They go to the substation
that feeds your house
and they turn off that circuit.
OK, suppose every house
in your neighborhood
has a solar roof,
generating power?
Well, without those roofs,
you turn off the substation.
The linemen can go
work on the line.
It's safe.
The line's dead.
If everybody's got
a generator, you
have to make sure
they're all disconnected.
And as a former dean
of engineering said,
let's say-- let's say, there
are 200 of them on the line.
What's the probability that all
of them disconnect properly?
Oh, that's zero, close to it.
So that's an issue
that's troublesome.
Not impossible.
There are standards
being developed.
There are technologies
That requires investment.
The policy problem is trickier.
Shouldn't be, but it is.
So it goes like this.
I get an electric
bill from Instar.
The electric bill has two
components, my kilowatt hour
consumption times an energy
charge, which is roughly
what they pay for
electricity on the market;
and the kilowatt hours I
consume times a capacity charge.
What's that?
Well, that's the
way they recover
the fixed cost of the wires.
So if I put a solar roof on,
I save the energy charge,
which the utility also saves,
and I save the capacity charge,
which they don't save.
So on the one hand, there's
an extra subsidy there.
In addition to whatever
other subsidies
I get for putting a solar roof
on, there's an extra subsidy.
I get this illusory extra
reduction in my electric bill.
It doesn't correspond to
anybody's cost reductions.
The costs are still there.
The wires are still there.
But I get a cut.
OK, that gives me
an extra incentive
to install a solar roof.
What about the utility?
Well, it gives the
utility every incentive
to make it hard for me
to install a solar roof.
It's money out of their pocket.
It's money they
don't get to cover
the fixed cost of the wires.
So I have a strong incentive--
a stronger incentive
to put up a solar roof.
And they have a strong
incentive to resist my
putting up a solar roof.
This is not a great policy.
if you care about solar roofs.
The fix is straightforward
conceptually.
That there ought to be a fixed
charge, x dollars a month,
that doesn't change with how
much electricity I consume.
And one way to convince
yourself that makes sense
is, suppose I install,
not a solar roof,
but I install a diesel
generator in my basement.
And the diesel generator--
which I vent the exhaust
into my neighbor's yard,
so that doesn't bother me--
so the diesel generator covers
all of my electric needs
when it runs.
But I still connect to
the grid for backup.
Now, if you're only charging
me for the kilowatt hours
I consume, I'm getting
the backup for free.
That doesn't make sense.
So there ought to
be a fixed charge.
It could vary with your
maximum consumption.
It could vary
with-- in Spain, you
contract for a certain maximum.
Your charge varies with that.
If you ever exceed that
maximum, it cuts you off;
very clever system.
So I would contract for backup.
I'd pay for it.
If the generator went
out, I pay a charge.
I'd pay for the power.
If the generator
doesn't go out, I still
pay for my share of the wires
that I have to have connecting.
Now, I will tell you, we
have made this presentation.
I've made this presentation.
Others have made
this presentation.
The state level, the federal
level, utilities, users,
everybody nods, and
says, yeah, of course,
but we can't do that.
How can we do that?
The usual argument is, well, it
would be unfair to poor people.
Well, it would be unfair to
poor people for everybody
to pay the same charge.
But why would everybody
pay the same charge?
Oh, but you then
have to discriminate.
Well, shouldn't people who
have used a lot of electricity,
and have the capacity to
use a lot of electricity,
pay more than those who don't?
Isn't that fair?
Well, no, that's too hard.
So this is a recommendation,
that as far as we can tell
has been floating around
for 20 years and more,
which may or may not
get adopted anywhere.
So finally, let me
do cybersecurity--
no clear authority.
So here's a picture
from NIST, that
is sort of what
the grid will look
like the, road map for the
smart grid interoperability
standards.
This is what they're
working off--
or a cartoon of what
they're working off
in generating standards.
And every one of those lines
is a communication line.
There's computation
in various places.
There's communication
along those lines.
And some of them are thousands
of pieces of equipment.
Some of them, down
here in households,
are millions of
pieces of equipment.
They all have to interoperate.
They all talk.
The standard setting
problem is hard enough.
But the fact is,
they're all talking.
That means there are all these
channels that can be hacked,
can have failures,
can be sabotaged.
There was a great demonstration
a couple of years ago,
done for purposes of a video.
A small turbine-- oh,
yeah, it was a diesel.
A small diesel
generator was run.
And they purposely
hacked the control system
and caused the
generator to connect
to the grid out of phase.
The generator blew up.
Now, that's a hack that
can take-- you take out
a large piece of equipment,
and that's not like days.
That could be months
to fix, or years.
So it's a serious issue.
Most people are aware of it.
But the response-- the
governmental response
is quite fragmented.
At the federal level,
there are standards.
There are some compliance--
some regulation.
Each state regulates
cybersecurity in its state.
And I remember talking to one
of the commissioners from Ohio.
And he said, oh,
we have workshops.
We're getting all these
guys to do standards.
This is fabulous.
I said, what about the municipal
utilities and the co-ops
in Ohio?
Oh, well, we invite
them to come.
There's no jurisdiction.
They're connected to the grid.
So no development
or coordination
of standards for
distribution systems.
Those are regulated by
the states or not at all.
And nobody deals
with the whole grid.
So it's pretty simple.
The simple recommendation,
somebody ought to be in charge.
There are people in
charge of cyber--
the Department of
Homeland Security
has a chart that shows
who's in charge of what.
And it goes industry
by industry, usually
a match of agencies.
Nobody's in charge
in electricity.
The latest-- the
latest statement
from the administration is, the
Department of Homeland Security
and the Department
of Energy will
coordinate on this subject.
Now, you don't have to spend
too much time in organizations
to realize that means
nobody's in charge.
Everybody-- this
is a recommendation
that everybody agrees with.
But there's violent
disagreement over who gets it.
The administration
has said it ought
to be the Department
of Homeland Security.
The relevant folks
in Congress say
it should be the
Department of Energy.
The current compromise that says
let them play nicely together
is something that
no one thinks--
no one outside the Beltway
thinks can possibly work.
So this is a look at
the future of the grid.
It's interesting.
We did this study
for two reasons.
One, because we got very
tired of hearing that we
have a third-world grid.
And it's all broken.
And we're all going to die.
That seemed a little extreme.
And then there's stuff
about how smart grids
are going to
transform our lives,
like the internet has
transformed our lives.
And we're all going to be active
participants in the electricity
market.
And that sounded even dumber.
And we thought it
might be worthwhile
getting some economists and
engineers to actually look
at the grid.
The conclusion we have is,
yeah, I mean, you can--
there's a way forward.
We're not in crisis.
There are real opportunities.
They're not transformative.
But they're real opportunities.
But there are problems.
We need to do relatively
inexpensive R&D,
I mean, this is a
software development,
algorithm development.
It's not nuclear power.
We need to be smarter about
siting transmission lines.
We need to move toward
getting retail prices right.
We need to deal with
network costs appropriately.
We need to deal
with cybersecurity.
If that all happens, you
will live happily ever after.
Questions?
Yeah, Matthew?
AUDIENCE: Earlier
in lecture, you
talked about how the
bill for the carbon tax
mentions nothing
about the environment.
What would happen if
it said, hey, this
is good for the environment,
too, as part of--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: I think
the environmental-- well,
it's not a bill yet.
There's no point in introducing
a bill into this Congress.
There will be-- it is expected--
the expectation is that after
the election, when there's
some hope of people
actually working together,
a short window, that
proposals for a carbon tax
are going to come leaping
out of the closet.
And those proposals
will talk about revenue.
And the environmentalists
will be relatively quiet
because if the environmentalists
talk about climate,
the Republicans,
who have said there
is no such thing as climate,
will be backed into a corner,
even though-- some
of them have had
to deny climate change to be
in line with the leadership,
even though they actually
are capable of words
of more than one syllable.
So some of those folks would
be pushed to opposition.
If you don't mention
climate, they
can quietly say, yeah,
it's good for the climate
and vote for it.
I don't know if it's
going to happen.
It's a cocktail
parity conversation.
But it appears to be a fairly
serious cocktail parity
conversation.
Anything else?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are you
going to be presenting
tomorrow [INAUDIBLE]?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
I'll be presenting
a longer version of this to a--
and a somewhat different
version, but close to it--
a group of large
electricity users.
And I'm very interested in what
they're going to have to say.
We've talked to
state commissioners.
We've talked to the
federal regulators.
We've talked to
congressional staff.
This is the first conversation
I've had with consumers.
So I'm looking forward
to it, big industrials.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is the problem
with cybersecurity
that nobody wants to deal with
it, or everybody wants to?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Everybody
wants to deal with it.
Yeah.
The problem is that the
Department of Homeland Security
has no expertise
in power systems.
And the Department of Energy has
no expertise in cybersecurity.
So whoever gets it
has to staff up.
Well, staffing up is fun.
You add headcounts.
You add people.
You add payroll.
You add prestige.
So whoever does it
gets to staff up.
If you split it, then you've
got sort of dueling staffs.
You don't understand
anything about electricity.
Oh, yeah.
But you don't understand
about security.
I mean, come on.
That doesn't work.
So everybody wants--
well, both people want it.
And at some point, I
assume, one of them
will be declared the
winner, but not soon.
Anything else?
OK, see you Wednesday.